du cinéma avec la sortie demain de
charlie et la chocolaterie avec johnny
depp
il s'agit de l'adaptation d'un gros
succès de la littérature pour enfants
plus de 13 millions d'exemplaires de ce
roman ont été vendus dans le monde
l'histoire d'un enfant pour qu'ils
découvrent l'univers fantastique d'une
fabrique de bonbons pascal deschamps
diane richard johnny depp et tim burton
un vrai couple de cinéma
le premier toujours à l'affût des rôles
que lui offrant le second des
personnages troublants ballotté dans des
univers étrange entre rêve et réalité d
aventure colorée dont il ya toujours une
leçon à tirer cette fois johnny depp et
wii ou encore le mystérieux propriétaire
d'une chocolaterie aux portes closes qui
décide un beau jour d'inviter des
visiteurs citoyen du monde
willy wonka est dessinée de permettre à
cinq enfants de visiter la chocolaterie
cinq tickets d'or ont été cachés dans le
papier d'emballage de sa tablette
ordinaire de chocolat rouille
cinq petits privilégiés et leurs parents
plongés dans une confiserie magique
un voyage initiatique semé d'embûches
un film tiré d'un best seller écrit
parole d'al un écrivain pour enfants qui
vivait en ermite et s'évader dans la
fiction il a gardé la fantaisie de
l'enfance c'est ce que j'aime dans son
oeuvre
sa sensibilité très proche de la mienne
il s'intéresse à la lumière et aux zones
d'ombré chez l'homme le tout avec
beaucoup d'humour c'est un chewing gum
phénoménal extraordinaire unique dans
tout les divers et pourquoi et pourquoi
parce que ces chewing gum et à lui tout
seul un repas complet et pourquoi les
gens n'achètent reach se promener dans
cette chocolat de vis et se promener
dans l'esprit de willy wonka quand comme
elle il est complexe étrange d'un drôle
et dérangeant de nos à l'inutile une
leçon de plaisir un film à savourer sans
peur des caries
sortie demain